you said a moment ago that it was near
certainty that children would would get
would get it now um what proportion of
children do you think have already had
it i know the ons estimate is estimated
recently 50 to 70 but what's your
estimate of it perhaps
it varies age um
and it does also vary by setting but i
think uh if we go for roughly half i
think that is a reasonable uh stab at
this
uh but but that obviously means you've
then got half who you know that's half
over the period of the entire
epidemic to date
and we've got quite a way to run we're
running into winter so there's quite
still quite a lot
of the damage that could be done to in
terms of disruption
you said there's a near certainty they
would get it but the estimates that
you've published on the gov dot uk
website of the effects of the vaccine um
is that if the children were vaccinated
to prevent 40 to 60 000 cases
so i appreciate you what you're assuming
in that that you get 60 vaccinations so
there's a potential for that to increase
you're talking about one and a half
million children in this age group that
have not had the disease already so why
is there such a big discrepancy between
those two numbers
uh well what we're assuming is firstly
the vaccines are not fully effective for
the reasons uh professor lim was talking
on and secondly we're assuming if you're
talking about you're assuming you're
talking about the modeling uh papers
that have been done yeah
you're saying you've got three million
children of which one and a half million
children have already had it and so the
argument faction's not really helping at
all so you've got one no that's not
actually well that's that let's come
back to that that's a that's not
actually strictly true but
okay
so so there's a group of people who've
not had it who i mean let's make an
assumption that the great majority of
children who have not currently had
covid are going to get it at some point
over the next period it won't be
necessary in the next two or three
months but they will get it sooner or
later because this is incredibly
infectious
and because immunity wanes we're not
going to see a situation where it just
sort of stops at a certain point so over
the next uh years we will see that
happening now vaccination will reduce
that risk
as professor lin was saying by i'm going
to say for the sake of argument 50 it's
probably slightly more than that but 50
for the sake of argument uh people
who've already had the infection some of
them will go on to get it a second time
that we know
uh and so the vaccination will further
reduce that number and it won't produce
a complete protection for those uh who
are vaccinated and we some people do so
some people who won't even get infected
at all but they were a really very small
number
you can put a lot of different
assumptions into this and the bit that
we don't know most and the one that's
got the biggest impact i think in the
medium to long term is how rapidly uh
does this wane in terms of protection
assuming no new variant and that's a
very strong very important assumption
but assuming no new variant that
probably is the thing we don't we don't
know most so the confidence intervals
around almost all of the numbers are
really quite wide so we can give broad
indications
of this but i think with all of these
and the modelers would agree with this
no one should put too much emphasis on
individual numbers i think you have to
see them as a central projection within
quite a wide range